thank you so much for joining us we have
been seeing the tributes pouring in from
all over the world I I think you know so
many of us are still so shocked by the
passing of Queen Elizabeth II what's the
general feeling right now
I think shock disbelief
um you know already a huge outpouring of
grief on the Streets of London people
knew this moment was coming but nothing
really prepares you and I think even
people who weren't particularly
interested in the queen or the monarchy
and perhaps didn't even believe in a
monarchy we'll find themselves taken
aback by this news because she has been
such
um a key part of our lives for so many
years and someone that for most of us
was the only monarch we've ever known
it's true I keep hearing the word
constant she's such a constant in our
lives that it feels strange not to have
her here anymore
absolutely and I think that is going to
take some time to sink in you know we're
going to have the new King in London
within hours and just hearing the word
King Charles III is very unusual and new
to us we're going to have new banknotes
new coins new stamps in in the fullness
of time and all of these things might
feel pretty uncomfortable at first I
think people have so much love and
respect for the queen and this is going
to be a huge defining moment in British
Society
oh absolutely you know it's really
interesting the queen appointed the new
prime minister just days ago
were there any indication that we were
leading up to this moment
look I think people weren't particularly
concerned about the queen earlier in the
week which they were
um no one was letting on personally I
felt that she looked very frail in that
photograph with Liz trucks
um obviously she has been looking
increasingly
small over recent months and yet that
still was not expected by the majority
of people earlier on today
I think you know we haven't seen as much
of her in recent weeks she had canceled
the privy council meeting yesterday and
then as soon as we had the statement
from the palace that she was under the
medical supervision it became very clear
that something quite seriously wrong was
going on and you know we heard you know
different members of the royal family
going to Balmoral it does sort of seem
like this was a surprise to them as well
I believe so I mean Charles and Camilla
had been nearby uh staying at Burke Hall
Princess Anne was also up in Scotland
carrying out engagements but other
members of the family weren't and you
know fortuitously Prince Harry and Megan
were in in the UK and he's been able to
travel up to be with his family this
evening
um we understand that the news broke
while he was still in mid-air
um so that's incredibly sad for him but
I think that hopefully being there all
together will bring them all some
comfort
now do we know why Meghan Markle didn't
join him while he was traveling to
Balmoral look we've not been told why I
mean the Duchess of Cambridge has not
traveled up to Balmoral either yet
obviously it was her children's first
full day at their new school today
that's a lot to manage and you know
obviously there are lots of children
involved who need a parent at their side
as well to guide them through this very
difficult family moment so you know
we're being told not to read too much
into it at this moment I'm sure further
details will emerge
I understand so what is going to happen
next what does the next week look like
well first and foremost we're going to
see King Charles III and his Queen
consort Camilla returning to London and
I would expect some public appearances
from them we'll have an address from the
new king to the nation and to the
Commonwealth at some point as well
there'll be gun salutes there'll be all
manner of
rehearsals gearing up let's not forget
that planning around this operation
London Bridge as it was known has been
ongoing for decades now so it's a very
well-oiled well choreographed setup and
yet you know the reality of
um coordinating these events with
potentially millions of people on the
Streets of London is going to be all
together different from whatever they
might have on paper
it's true do we have any details about
the funeral
so a date for the funeral hasn't been
confirmed as we're speaking right now
um we understand it's to be around 10
days following
um the dates of the Queen's passing but
that may alter it won't take place for
example on a Sunday as far as we know
um but Palace sources are Keen to stress
that you know there are lots of working
parts in this situation there is a lot
that people have been briefed over the
years to expect but may change and is
still awaiting um sign off by the new
King in fact
I know how much you love the royal
family I know you've been following
members of the royal family for years
now how is this going to impact you
this is a huge moment for me both
professionally and personally you know
I'm with my professional hat on this is
a story I've been obviously preparing
for for many years
um from from a personal point of view
though it's I think it probably hasn't
hit me yet I think that in the coming
days it will and I think that while
obviously the queen was 96 years old
she'd had a remarkable life
um there's still huge sadness and it's
to do with this figure who's so deeply
ingrained on our psyche no longer being
there and that's going to take some time
to get used to Emily do we have any
details whatsoever surrounding how the
queen passed we don't yet have
confirmation of why the queen passed
away
um my understanding is it's obviously
something that happened fairly rapidly
over the last couple of days but she's
not been in good health quite some time
now and you know the palace has been
very careful to preserve her medical
confidentiality she may have been the
most famous woman in the world but she
was still entitled to that privacy
around medical issues we may however
find out later on what happened